you have to
have to and get
up even though it may hurt we caught up
to singer-songwriter Abraham Alexander
in a moment
sinking with the message of his music
from his debut album Seasons what was it
that went into this album I think
vulnerability
and honesty fear were the elements
within the record when
you're trying to figure out who you are
the quickest place that you look for is
childhood born in Greece his Nigerian
parents had immigrated hoping for a
better life in Greece your playground
was the Parthenon Parthenon and the
Acropolis and I would ride my bike and I
would go out till
late at night and it was so freeing
freeing but also at times hostile one
day it came to a head at a grocery store
I brushed up on a bag of chips and it
fell down and I grabbed the chips and I
put it back on the Shelf
and someone walked in and said
why'd you touch that no one's going to
buy that now
and then
the whole Supermarket started to gang up
on us and we had to leave they then came
to America settling in Arlington Texas
was it the land of milk and honey for
you I was just excited to be somewhere
different excited to be somewhere with
possibilities but tragedy struck when
his mother was killed by a drunk driver
he lost his younger brother too but his
Saving Grace were his adoptive parents I
wonder if I stayed
he pours it all into his music
[Music]
pain struggle Joy regret and the
realization he might have missed tuning
into his gift because of his complicated
relationship with his father a jazz
musician himself I wanted nothing to do
with music and it wasn't until later on
that I picked up the guitar and it it
was as if someone gave me a pen for the
first time the right time just before a
serendipitous encounter as I was waiting
outside I see these two individuals
offloading amps into the building and I
went out and they said we're recording
this individual named Leon Bridges
and asked me if I could sing and I said
no
and then they asked can you hum and I
said yes I think I could hum
Alexander would hum on Bridges
grammy-nominated album coming home and
then was offered some advice it was Leon
that told me that I should try doing
open mics and I should write some songs
and see where it takes me and I'm
forever grateful for him you know
because he saw the passion within me a
passion that launched opportunities
performing with other artists
but it's his own music that now offers
him both insight and relief
[Music]
and the ability to speak out against the
horror of Injustice the song Deja Vu was
inspired by the story of khalifriday who
was a young child who was wrongfully
accused of still in a backpack and spent
three years in Rikers Island tell the
truth it'll set you free
legendary
Mavis Staples accompanies him the power
that she exudes within that song is so
gracious and everything that makes me
this Mavis she ingests within the song
and I'm so grateful for her for doing
that it's it's surreal
oh I was definitely meticulous a bit
about being open rather than being ready
and I think it's important to be open
rather than being ready because you'll
never be ready